Used to be a carpenter.
When I came to America, I learned how to be a carpenter.
I was a drug dealer, but also a carpenter.
(dramatic music)
This buddy of mine, Dav,
he had a side job for me to do on the weekends.
He calls me Fetch.
So he said, Hey, Fetch,
do you wanna do a side job on the weekend?
I says, yeah, what is it?
He says, it's at a fortune teller.
It's up in Laguna Honda.
You have to, you have to like,
she wants to build a couple of walls or some shit.
I was like okay.
But the night before I was on like a really bad bender.
So I was dying while I was working.
And I was thinking about killing myself
while I was working at this fortune teller's,
and I'm thinking, you know what,
when I'm done here, I'll go to the fucking bridge,
the Golden Gate Bridge.
And then I was thinking,
fuck, you know, there's a net around the Golden Gate Bridge.
So if you jump in the wrong place, you'll end up in the net.
So I was thinking, fuck, knowing my luck,
I'd probably end up in the fucking net, you know?
And I'm nailing my studs.
And this is while I'm working, I'm debating with myself,
how I'm gonna kill myself.
And the fortune teller is watching me.
And she looks at me, and she goes,
oh my God, you have a wonderful aura.
And I was, I just, it was so ridiculous, I laughed out loud.
The ridiculousness of what she said to me
snapped me out of it for that day.
It was so, so bizarre like I had so many of those moments.
Yeah, little, little interventions.
Yeah.
Today we're gonna spin an addiction to recovery yarn,
old school style.
A what it was like, what happened,
and what it's like now vibe.
So gird your loins because this story
is pretty fucking wild.
The teller of said story is my friend, Richie Stevens.
Richie is an Irish gangster turned actor
turned sober storyteller.
Best known for playing, you guessed it, gangsters
and hardened criminals in a long line
of movies and television procedurals.
Given Richie's past as a drug trafficker, a kidnapper,
a drug addict, an alcoholic,
and basically an all around criminal himself,
it's a bit of a real life Barry situation.
And it's a tale that he lets loose
in his wildly entertaining and darkly comic new book,
"The Gangster's Guide to Sobriety,"
which chronicles Richie's descent into the abyss
and his slog to redemption.
And also, it's currently being developed
into a television series by the creators of the hit TV show
"Silicon Valley."
I've known Richie for about a decade.
The arc of this guy's life
is truly one for the record books.
He's a hell of a storyteller.
This one is gonna blow your hair back.
The chaos and the insanity is off the charts,
but it will also make you realize
that if this guy could go from where he was
to where he is today, that truly anything is possible.
A little alert for the more squeamish out there,
there's a fair amount of profanity and tales of violence
throughout this conversation.
But with that warning, please hit that subscribe button
and enjoy, the hang.
It's always cool when I get to have friends on the show.
And I was thinking back to when we first met,
and I can't remember the very first time,
but it has to have been at least 10 years.
At least, maybe nine at least.
Yeah, yeah.
So you moved to, you moved to LA in 2010?
No, I think it was 2013.
Yeah, oh, 2013.
Okay, so yeah, maybe just under 10 years.
And I just, I just remember,
I have like a vague memory
of you just telling insane stories, and I was thinking,
God, man, this guy's full of shit.
There's no way this stuff is real, you know?
Well, yeah, that's the,
well, the first person to read like my original manuscript
was the book agents.
Well, besides my partners,
and the original one was like really long.
It was like 105,000 words, 430 pages,
and they read it twice, and they were like, this is crazy.
Like it can't be true,
but there's so much detail in it, it could be true.
And then they were like, did this really happen?
You know, like this is great, but how do we sell this
because it's just like a crazy long story?
Just on and on and on with like one insane story
after the next.
So what was the decision to cut it down to be, you know,
such a relatively small book?
Well, so we rewrote the book.
Like my original book
was just all of my experiences written down.
And then I partnered up with John and Dave
cause they wanna make a TV show out of it.
And they were like, it's not really accessible.
So we need to like reformat it somehow
so it's relatable to people
cause most people don't know who I am.
So it's like why do you care about this guy?
You know, but so I got sober with the,
using the 12 steps by going to meetings.
And they were like, why don't we format it
like how you got sober through the 12 steps
and each chapter will be thematically written around a step.
Right, so each chapter is a step
with your own kind of like spin on the subtitle
for that step.
The forward is just, or, well, the guys wrote a forward.
And then the first chapter
is you breezing through the whole story
from like 10,000 feet.
So you get a sense of just how crazy your life has been.
And then each chapter takes you through the steps
and uses stories from your past
to illustrate how you work the step,
which I thought was a really cool
kind of narrative technique.
Yeah, exactly.
And I guess it's more relatable for people now.
It's not too long.
It's under 200 pages.
So, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it's a good yarn, dude,
and nobody loves a good addiction recovery yarn
more than this guy.
So well done my friend,
and it's exciting that it's gonna be out in the world,
and such an amazing arc given where you came from
to where you are now.
And I thought it would be cool
to just format this conversation around what we know best,
which is what it was like, what happened,
and what it's like now.
We can kind of do it like a meeting, you know, so?
Okay.
Take us back and like paint the crazy picture
of growing up in this small town in Ireland
and how it kind of all went insane.
Yeah, so I'm, you know, born and raised in Ireland.
I came to America in my early 20s, and where I'm from,
it's like middle of nowhere, you know, countryside,
and when I was a kid, I was like,
I was really shy and quiet, you know.
I didn't have a lot of self confidence.
And you know, where I grew up was like a tough place.
You know?
Like if you compare it to America,
like when I was growing up,
men where I'm from, don't drink cocktails.
You know, men don't drink cocktails.
Men don't really use umbrellas.
Like it rains a lot in Ireland,
and you might see like a doctor or a teacher maybe
carry an umbrella because it's pissing rain all the time,
and just standing out in it.
Yeah, I started smoking when I was like a teenager,
and cigarettes were a bit harsh on my throat.
So I saw these menthols.
So I started smoking menthols at the start, you know,
and somebody saw me smoking menthols,
and they says, are you fucking pregnant?
You know, like, that's the kinda spot it was
when I was growing up.
So it's, the town is called Cavan.
How do you pronounce it?
Cavan's the county.
C-A-V-A-N, Cavan.
And what's interesting about that.
I actually like went to Google maps and pulled down pictures
cause I wanted to get a visual sense
of what that place was like, and not a lot going on.
A lot of pictures of like a church.
That's kind of it,
but you grew up close to the border of Northern Ireland.
So you have this spillover of Protestants, right?
So you have Protestant,
the Protestant/Catholic kind of tension that was going on
that I'm sure kind of underscored, you know,
just the whole vibe of growing up there.
Yeah, like, so where I grew up is at the border,
so the border of Northern Ireland.
There was a lot of like,
I guess, terrorists around there, you know,
because it's at the border, and I'm Catholic, you know.
I was raised Catholic, but my dad was a Protestant.
So I have a Protestant name.
Like in Ireland, if you're a Catholic,
you'll have a name like O'Reilly or McDonald
or something like that.
But if you're Protestant,
you have like a British sounding name.
So my name's Richie Stevens.
So like I sound like I'm Protestant.
And then I was sent to like a Catholic school.
And wasn't a whole lot of fun, as you can imagine.
Like in Ireland maybe when I was growing up,
where I'm from maybe 90% of people were Catholic.
10% were Protestant.
Well, my mother was like devout Catholic.
So we were all sent to Catholic schools, but I hated it.
You know?
It wasn't, it wasn't easy.
Like, you know, a lot of people kinda romanticized the IRA,
you know, the terrorist group over there.
And you know, I got dog's abuse in the school
because you know.
Right, even though you were in Catholic school
and were raised Catholic, you had this Protestant last name.
Exactly.
So it puts like a target on your back.
Exactly, yeah, yeah.
And I was, you know, I used to let myself get pushed around.
I used to always worry about things.
It was like I was very, very self-conscious all the time.
Like where I'm from, it's really important
to play like football, Gaelic football,
and that's all really people care about in the area.
So it's like, if you go to a bar with your parents
and you meet somebody, the first thing they'll say is
does this man play football?
And you could be a fucking brain surgeon,
and if you didn't play football, you were no good.
Yeah.
You know, so I played football, but I was no good at it.
I had zero talent for it no matter how hard I tried,
but it's kinda like if you didn't tog out,
that's what they call it.
Like, just show up, you were no good.
Like, so I played football, but I was never any good at it.
You know, every time I would play a game, if I get the ball,
I would be like, oh, I wouldn't, I wouldn't,
I'd be so self-conscious.
I wouldn't even know what to do.
Like and I would just get nailed all the time
by the other players.
And you know, I tried to fit in as best as I could,
but what really did it for me was the drinking.
You know, I started off, I went to a concert one time,
like I was about 14 or 15.
I went to this concert over on the west coast.
It was Beastie Boys, Garbage,
all these kind of bands, and a girl on the bus
on the way home gave me a beer to see if I wanted a drink,
like, and I said, okay.
I tried this drink, and then I was like,
it was like, wow, it's like.
Lights went on.
I didn't care what anybody thought about me.
I had zero fear about anything.
I was like, this is like the special sauce
that I wanna drink all the time, you know?
Yeah, I mean, I really related to that
sense of internal turmoil that you experienced
as a young person, just feeling like
out of place all the time, not comfortable in your own skin.
That sense of self consciousness
and kind of free flowing anxiety, and what was interesting,
what I didn't know was that you grew up
like a pretty good kid,
like the book's called "The Gangster's Guide to Sobriety,"
but it's not like you grew up
in a notorious Irish crime family.
No.
Like you grew up with parents who cared for you,
and you know, your needs were met,
and you were kind of a shy, introverted kid.
So all the insanity, you know, doesn't spawn from.
No, no, I can't.
A completely dysfunctional family situation.
No, I can't blame that on anybody.
Like, you know, I have a brother and sister who are normal,
like, and as far as I know,
like nobody in my family has ever been in trouble
with the law before, so.
Right.
I'm like the black sheep, but it was weird
because some people can just have a few drinks
and nothing happens, and then there's just certain people
who just the rule book goes out the window,
and I was that kind of a person, you know,
and that's how it affected me.
Right, and in, I would suspect
like in the area in which you grew up
there wasn't a real appreciation
for the disease of alcoholism, right?
It's just like people drink, that's what happens.
Yeah, you get outta control once in a while,
but that ain't nothing but a thing.
Yeah, like where I'm from,
it's like a sign of masculinity to be able to drink a lot.
You know, like where I'm from, they'll say,
oh, that guy's a warrior for the drink, you know?
And so if you can't handle your drink,
that's not a good thing.
But my definition of what an alcoholic was
was somebody who's homeless, can't hold down a job.
You know, maybe they're smelly.
You know, like that's what I thought
an alcoholic actually was.
So I had a problem with the sauce from very young,
but I never really made the connection
until I was a lot older cause I know now that I was like
a functional, quote unquote alcoholic.
If you could call it functional.
Yeah, very industrious and entrepreneurial.
Yeah, in my own head, I was, yeah,
I was keeping the show on the road.
Yeah.
Yeah, but it did something for me
that I didn't have beforehand.
You know, it kind of, it was my solution to how I felt.
So you have that epiphany on the bus ride,
coming back from the concert,
having the drink because the pretty girl asked you to.
You have this sense, like, oh, this is the solution
to the problem I didn't even know that I had,
so where does it go from there?
For me, like just in reading the book and knowing you,
it was, it's pretty incremental.
Like that's a very innocent kind of introduction to alcohol
that probably is extremely common.
Like a lot of people have their version of that,
but that relationship to alcohol
and what it meant to you at that time
sets in motion a chain of events
that just spiral crazy outta control.
Yeah, it didn't happen overnight, the craziness.
It was kind of, the problem was with me,
there was no predicting how it would end up.
Like sometimes I could have a few scoops
and score with a woman and go home and everything was fine.
And then there's other times I would black out,
wake up on the floor of someone's living room, you know.
There was no predicting, you know, but I didn't care.
Like for me it was worth it
for the ease and comfort that I got out of it,
it was really worth it.
And like the way it works in Ireland, if you're,
it's 18 to drink in a bar or a club, right?
And I was 15, maybe 14 or 15 when I started drinking,
and I wanted to drink with the grownups.
Like I wanted to go to clubs and bars,
but the problem was you needed an ID.
I still look pretty young.
I have a baby face like,
and so I decided to start making fake IDs.
And first I just made one for myself
and a couple of my friends, and it was great.
It worked.
I could go to all the bars, and you know,
all the other kids heard that I had a fake ID.
So a few people asked me to make them,
and they said they'd pay me, and that's how it started.
I had this buddy,
he was a year older than me in school.
We'll call him Walter for the sake of the story.
Yeah, I was wondering if you anonymized all these people.
I had to, yeah, the lawyers made me, you know.
Well, some people are dangerous.
You don't wanna, you know,
you don't wanna tempt faith, but, so yeah, Walter,
he came up with the idea.
He said, why don't you make the IDs
and I'll sell them, and we'll have a business,
and we can make a bunch of money?
And I said, okay.
And the way it, first I started making IDs
for all the people in my school.
And then I was making them for people in other schools
who I'd never met before.
I had like a--
What were you charging for an ID?
It was really cheap, cheap.
It was like five bucks.
Should have charged more.
Yeah, I know.
But I was only doing it for some drinking money.
I wasn't trying to become a king pin or something like that.
But yeah, it just got outta control,
but it was great cause like I would go
everywhere around the county.
You were popular.
Yeah, I was popular.
You go from being this kind of quiet kid
to suddenly being the guy that is in high demand.
Yeah, yeah, it was, it was fun.
And I had all this, like I was broke,
so I got all this drinking money from it,
and I could go to different bars and clubs,
and people would like I'd already shown them my ID before.
So they knew my name and what I drank
and all this kinda stuff.
It was, and I was just a kid.
Right, what's great though is that you get busted
for this racket.
You get charged with like offense of the state
or something like that because of the official seal
or something like that that you figured out how to create
in a unique way that like freaked out the authorities.
Well, basically the way IDs worked in Ireland back then,
you get what's a police ID
or in Ireland is called the Garda.
So you have a Guard ID.
So I was copying the Guard ID
cause it was an official ID.
But back then it was like, it was easy to make one.
It was kinda like,
it was like a card, a blue card.
And then typewriter would have your name
and your date of birth, and then in the back,
there was a stamp.
It was like a police stamp.
And I was able to forge the stamp in order, you know,
that was tricky enough.
But what happened was Walter got caught,
and he rolled over on me, and you know,
I found out about it.
I was out of the house one day, and I came home
and my mother says, the police were looking for you.
I said, fuck, what happened?
She goes, that friend of yours fucking told the police
you were making the IDs.
I was like, oh God.
And so I had to go in and like talk to the police,
you know, have an interview.
And it was nerve wracking, you know.
They thought I had either stolen a stamp
from the police station
or maybe there was some kind of a mole or something.
You know, they didn't know how I had, how I was doing it.
So I had to go in and explain to them
that the way I make these is I just make the stamp
on my computer.
I print it onto like an old photograph.
You know, like a glossy photograph.
Like an inkjet printer if you print onto a photograph,
and if it's glossy, it'll stay wet.
Yeah, it doesn't dry.
Yeah, so basically I would print it onto an old photo
and then stamp it onto the card,
and then it looks like a stamp.
But you had to print it in reverse, right?
Yeah, I had to print it in reverse.
Cause if you do that, it comes up backwards, right?
So eventually I figured this shit out,
and I was trying to explain to the cops, and like they were,
I was like a 15, 16 year old kid,
and they were, they were listening.
They're like, Jesus, huh?
Jesus.
You know, cause they must have thought
I was some kind of a criminal genius.
Right, right.
But yeah, they were like, they were like,
these are very serious charges.
Cause that's like what they charge terrorists with.
Cause terrorists in Ireland,
they make fake documents and stuff like that.
And my friend Walter,
his family were known to be terrorists as well.
So the fact that I was working with him was kind of,
they had, well, they wanted to get to the bottom of it.
And in the end I just pretended
I only made a couple of them.
I'm sorry.
I only made a couple from my friends.
I won't do it again.
And I hadn't been in trouble before.
So they let me away with it, and I got away.
Right, so a couple observations on that.
First of all, this is your first brush with the law.
And also, you know, the first kind of like true resentment
with a friend cause this guy Walter sold you out, right?
Yeah.
And that's where, you know,
the anger kind of enters the picture, right?
And anger plays a much bigger role as you, you know,
walk this path.
But I'm curious about like where you think
like what is the genesis of that anger?
Like you, you know, like you would have
these crazy outbursts,
and you get in all these fights later on
and stuff like that.
Like what is that about
and how have you kind of made peace with that
or resolve it?
Well, I think originally
because I used to get pushed around in school
like because my old man was a Protestant,
like so in Ireland where I'm from
like a derogatory thing that they'll say to somebody
who's Protestant,
they'll say you're a Black cunt, you know.
Not Black as in the color of your skin,
but back in the old days, like in the 19-teens
or whatever, after World War I,
there were these British soldier group
called the Black and Tans,
and they came to Ireland,
and they massacred a bunch of people and stuff like that.
So when they're calling you Black,
they're calling you one of those Black and Tans,
like, so I was pushed around at school
because of that kinda stuff, so I think when I was,
when I was little and I had no confidence or no courage,
it, you know, that affected me.
And then after I started drinking,
and I had this psychological change
made me a different person,
then I was like determined not to take any shit from anybody
because of how I had been treated when I was younger,
you know?
Yeah, so I think I probably had a little bit of a,
it took a, it took a while for that to grow, you know?
Like even when I first started drinking,
I don't know what it's like now,
but when I was growing up back home,
Ireland was like violent, you know.
Not a lot of people getting murdered,
but when you go out drinking, everybody used to drink a lot.
And then at the end of the night,
we would go to these fast food restaurants.
They call them chippers back home
cause they sell fries.
Yeah.
Like fish and chips, you know?
And after the night of drinking,
everybody goes to the chipper,
and that's when you would see the fights, you know?
Cause you have.
It's like sport.
It's like a spectator sport though.
Oh, absolutely, yeah.
And I used to sit in the chipper
and watch these fucking boys trolling each other,
beating each other.
It was, it was mayhem.
And when I was like, when I first came to America,
I was only 160 pounds.
I was light, you know?
So back then I was like a skinny, light kid,
but I'm like taking all this shit in,
and it was kind of, it was really exciting.
It was like an action movie in front of you.
Yeah.
You know? And it was funny.
Sometimes it was like,
sometimes it would be over nothing.
Like say you're in the chipper,
and there's a guy there with his woman,
and a drunk guy like gives her the eye.
He could get knocked out for that, you know?
Or he spills some chips on somebody.
You'd see them flying over tables.
It reminds me of that scene in "The Gentleman."
You see that movie?
Where Colin Farrell beats the shit of out of a bunch of kids
in a chipper, you know, that idea.
Yeah, that could happen anytime.
But, and when I first started going out,
I used to work at a gas station.
Back in the day,
there was people called gas station attendants
who would come and fill your gas for you.
Like now everybody just, everybody fills their own gas.
But that was my first job.
I was like 15 or 16.
And I was working with these older boys.
And one of them, I probably shouldn't say his name,
but his nickname was Tits
cause he had man boobs, you know,
but Tits used to bring me out, and I used to look up to him.
You know, he was one of these guys,
when I first met him, he had been arrested like 30 times
just for like fighting or stupid drunk shit,
and he never went to jail
cause when I was growing up, there was like,
there was no real penalties for that.
Like in California, I couldn't believe when I got here,
there's not a whole lot of fights
because if you like just put your hand on someone
or spit on them, you're going to jail.
But back home you could kick the shit outta someone,
and maybe if the cops got you,
you might have to go to court
and pay a couple of hundred dollars fine.
That's all it was.
There was like a boys will be boys' mentality to the law.
I don't--
Is it still like that there?
I don't know.
It might not be, but when I was growing up,
that's how it was.
Right.
And I used to hang out with Tits, and he'd bring me out,
and you know, he was kind of a role model for me.
Yeah.
You know.
What is the truth or the lived experience
of growing up around the IRA?
Cause I, you know, my relationship to that
is just what I've read in books or seen in movies.
Well, you know what, I'll tell you,
I'll tell you the main thing
that Hollywood never gets right about the IRA.
Like whenever you see the movies or anything like that,
about the IRA, they make it out
like it's this really fucking secret thing
where these guys come out of nowhere,
and nobody knows who they are, but in real life,
you know exactly who's in the IRA.
Cause in Ireland, like it's a small country.
Everybody knows everybody.
So if your neighbor is in the IRA, you know.
Like if their kid is on the team with you,
everybody knows because they have marches and shit,
and you see them at the marches,
or they might come to the bar to collect money
for whatever the prisoners
or whatever the fuck they're collecting money for.
So in real life, everybody knows exactly who's in the IRA.
So there's no secret, you know, but it's still.
And you just sort of tip toe around it and tread lightly.
It depends.
I have a load of friends who were in it
and whose families are in it.
You know, the way it is as well,
it's like a volunteer sort of a thing, so.
They're called volunteers,
so some people join up for awhile,
and then they go away again.
And that's how it is like.
Right.
You know, but I always ended up with being friends
with a bunch of their kids
cause there were a lot of 'em were kinda wild like I was.
You know?
Yeah, wow.
So the drinking starts to escalate.
Hash enters the picture.
At some point you start kind of selling,
dealing a little bit, like walk me through that next phase.
It was the exact same shit as the drinking.
With the drinking, I started selling IDs
to fund my drinking, and then with the hash,
I started, like I felt,
I started smoking hash when I was maybe 16 or 17 too,
and it, cause it was, I knew it couldn't kill you.
And it looked cool, you know?
And I had seen it on TV and movies and stuff like that.
And so I wanted to try it,
and I met these guys one night in Cavan.
Can't really use their names.
Let's call 'em,
this guy has a really obvious name.
We'll call him Pigeon, right?
All right, there you go.
So I met Pigeon and his buddy one night, and he goes,
do you wanna buy some hash, hi?
They have all this funny way of talking.
You think my way is funny.
They have all this weird lingo.
Like where I'm from, they'll say hi, Sham, or hi, Sobla.
They'd say, hi, Sham.
You wanna buy some hash, hi?
They say hi about everything.
It's weird.
So I says, yeah, how much is it?
He goes, I give you a five spot.
It was five pounds at the time.
Now we have euros, but back then we had pounds.
So he like sold me this little ball of hash,
and it was in a matchbox,
and he said, do you know how to smoke it?
I said no.
And he rolled me a joint, and we smoked it together.
And it was like,
it was like discovering alcohol all over again,
Except not so crazy.
It was more chilled.
Like there was no, you wouldn't fall down on hash really.
You probably couldn't crash a car on it, you know?
But once I discovered the hash too,
it was something that I wanted to do all the time,
even though I knew it was illegal.
I had to be careful not to get caught, but yeah.
I started to sell it to fund my use of it.
Yeah, and what's going on at home at this time?
Like what's mom aware of?
Oh, I kept it quiet from the parents.
You know, like I led a double life really with my folks.
And even with my wife and everything down through the years,
I would do a lot of secret shit.
You know, I would,
I would stay over with friends, and you know,
sometimes I would come home,
and my poor mother would be like sitting in the kitchen
at four o'clock in the morning waiting for me,
and I'd walk in the door drunk, and you know,
I felt bad about it, but I still felt like it was worth it
at the time.
Well, it's also that thing
where you think you're getting away with this,
that double life, that they're not aware
of what you're doing, but it's pretty transparent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it is what it is like.
Yeah, I put my poor parents through a lot,
you know, because later when I got into trouble,
everybody around knows everybody and stuff like that.
So when I got into trouble later, I got caught dealing.
Everybody knew, you know?
Right.
I mean, how are they now?
What do they think about this book
and this potential TV show and all of that?
It must be a mindblower.
Well.
Back, have you, you probably haven't been,
have you been back home at all?
Oh yeah, I've been home a lot of times.
Yeah, I'm sure they don't like the stuff being brought up,
but it is what it is.
It's a positive story.
I turn my life around.
It's not like I'm still doing this kind of stuff, you know?
Yeah, but just the idea
that like there's a book out there,
and you're kind of being feted, celebrated.
Yeah, well, you know, my mother like said to me,
she goes, Jesus Christ.
You're not, you're not worried
about people knowing what you did?
And I'm like, if I gave a fuck,
I wouldn't have wrote it in a book.
Like, you know, I'm sorry you feel that way,
but that's only natural I suppose.
But that's that shame thing, right,
that kind of emanates out of Catholicism.
Yeah.
Like we keep our, we keep our weaknesses private.
Yeah, yeah, and you know, when I was a kid, I was like,
I was super into the Catholicism.
Like even though I didn't like being forced
to go to church every week, I was an altar boy
at the church, and that shit used to make me nervous
as well because you gotta stand,
sit up in front of everybody at the front of the church.
And you know, if you're altar boy,
you have to like ring the bell at certain times
during the thing, and I would always be so nervous
about that shit as well.
I'd either miss the fucking time I was supposed to do it
or ring it too early,
or it was fucking mortifying, you know?
Same shit with the water and the wine.
You bring over the water and the wine to the priest
at a certain time,
and I was always fucking that up, you know?
Well, when you get sober though,
and you're kind of confronted
with the idea of embracing a higher power,
Catholicism didn't exactly, you know, strike you
as a good option at the time.
No, by the time I got sober.
Like there's a sour relationship.
Yeah, well just God in general.
When I got sober, I was a complete atheist.
I didn't believe there could be a God.
Like I just, the way I saw it was
God is like something that people believe in
when they're children like Santa Claus, you know,
and all these bad things had happened to me.
And I just didn't believe that there could be a God,
you know, and that's the way I felt before I got sober.
Yeah.
(upbeat music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores
of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change: Volume Two."
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation
of the magic, inspiration, and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on "The Rich Roll Podcast."
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table, and volume two
follows in that tradition by showcasing even more
of my favorite conversations in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography, making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained within.
"Voicing Change Volume Two" available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
All right, so let's pick the story back up.
Like you're starting to deal a little bit.
You end up going to college.
You kind of put the foot on the gas on the dealing.
Ecstasy enters the picture.
Like let's, you know,
this hurricane is starting to pick up speed.
Yeah, so I got to college,
and by the time I got to college,
I was a regular hash smoker and a regular drinker.
And, you know, I wasn't afraid to fight,
or I wasn't afraid to score with the women.
And I was just, I was dealing a little bit of hash,
and then I met my friend Tamo.
So Tamo kinda of changed everything.
I was introduced to him by my friend Ferret,
And he was called Ferret
because he talks really fast.
He sounds like a ferret, but yeah,
so Ferret introduced me to Tamo,
and he was a real character.
He was always talking about where he's from.
Apparently he used to deal a lot of ecstasy.
Kind of, people talk a lot of shit, so I was always,
I was always skeptical, you know,
and we used to hang out with Tamo.
He'd be telling us about these tall tales
about how he was dealing ecstasy in his hometown
and all this kinda shit.
And one night we were all drinking around Halloween.
We were over at my place.
We were drinking a load of beer and smoking hash.
And we decided to go for a walk around the neighborhood.
And there was, there was a house party going on.
And so we walked up to the house party.
It was like four or five of us.
It was me, Ferret, Pat the Rat, and Tamo.
He was called Pat the Rat cause he kinda looks like a rat.
He wasn't a snitch.
Also lots of Pats, right?
So every Pat had to have like an appendage.
Yeah, if you're Irish, you'll know a lot of Pats,
a lot of PJs, all that sort of,
so a lot of boys that I knock around would have nicknames.
So we saw this house party going on.
And we walked up, and we rang the doorbell.
Some dude answered the door,
and we're like, oh, can we come into your party?
And they were like, they were like, no, no,
we don't know you.
You can't come in.
So we're like fuck.
And then they closed the door on us.
We went back to the house, and we're drinking again.
Fuck those pricks, wouldn't let us into the party.
And Tamo had like a bottle of wine there, and he goes,
he goes, Mush, do you dare me to come back
and put this through their fucking window?
We were, we were, oh, it's always funny shit.
He's never gonna do that.
And we were like, yeah, we dare you.
Do it.
So we walked back around the block again,
and Tamo got the fucking wine bottle,
just fucked it through the window,
like straight through the window of the fucking house.
We were like, wow, Tamo is fucking crazy.
He actually did it.
Like we all ran away.
Like, you know, and then, and then after that,
I was like, wow, Tamo is the real deal.
He's, this guy isn't a bullshitter or anything, you know?
And then, so me and Tamo were out one night,
there's a bar called the LA, Leinster Arms.
We were in the Leinster Arms, and I knew Tamo did ecstasy,
but I was afraid to do ecstasy because I thought, you know,
in the news you read these stories
about how people took ecstasy one time,
and they fucking died and then.
I always thought like I'm kind of unlucky.
So that would probably be me if I took the ectasy one time.
So Tits used to do it, my old friend from Cavan,
but I used to hang out with him while he was on ecstasy.
But I was always scared to do it
cause I thought I would be that unlucky person
that it kills.
And then one night we're out in the LA, me and Tamo,
and he goes, Mush, do you wanna try one of these ecstasy?
And I was like, well, I don't know it might fucking,
I'm afraid it might kill me, you know?
He goes, Mush, these are light ones.
They're really light.
They're not strong.
You'll be grand.
So he handed me this double,
this beige pill with 007 on it.
And I saw this pill, and he goes, go on, take one the fuck.
Go into the bathroom.
Take it.
So I went into the bathroom.
I was really scared.
I had this fucking 007 pill in my hand,
and I was thinking, hmm, Tamo's smart.
And they haven't killed him.
Maybe I'd be okay with it, you know?
So I said, fuck it, a half wouldn't kill somebody.
A quarter definitely wouldn't.
So I took, I broke it in half,
and then I broke it in half again.
And I took a quarter,
and I put the other three quarters back into my pocket,
and I came back outside, and Tamo goes, did you take it?
And I was like, yep.
He goes, all right, let me know when you're coming up.
And then coming up means it started to take effect.
So maybe half hour later,
or three quarters of an hour later,
I'm not feeling anything.
Tamo says, are you coming up yet?
I was like, oh no.
He goes, did you take it all?
I was like, oh, I only took a half.
And he goes, Mush, take a whole one.
These were really light.
You gotta take a whole one.
So I went back in, took another quarter,
went back in, took another quarter.
And then eventually it started coming up,
and ecstasy was like nothing I had ever tried before.
It was, it's called ecstasy for that reason.
It actually feels like ecstasy.
I came out and I was like,
I loved everybody in the fucking place.
You know, I had no bad feelings.
It was overwhelming like, and I was just thinking,
fuck, why doesn't everybody on earth take these
all the time?
You know, I was thinking there would be no wars or anything.
This is fucking great.
And that night I ended up,
like I would be all sweaty, and my jaw would be hanging,
and my foot would be tapping, and music sounded good.
And I ended up taking two on my first night,
and it was kind of like,
it was like discovering alcohol all over again,
except 100 times better.
And I loved it.
And then ecstasy costs money as well.
So there was the financial problem
of paying for the ecstasy.
And I was the first one outta my friends to start taking it.
And then Pat the Rat started taking it,
and the other boys as well.
And so Tamo was kind of, he was,
I was sort of friendly, right?
Tamo was kinda quiet and antisocial.
So not a lot of people knew him.
So I was kinda like,
all my friends started taking them after me.
And we were all doing them together.
And a lot of people were telling me to get pills often
from Tamo, and so I was ending up getting 10 or 15 a night
for everybody and just getting them as a favor.
And Tamo says to me, he goes, Mush
why don't you take 100 of these?
And you can sell some of them, and then you get,
you get a bunch of money
and you get to do your own for free.
And I was like, oh no, no, that's dealing.
That's serious.
If the cops catch you dealing,
it wouldn't be like the IDs.
I'd fucking go to jail for that shit for years.
And he goes, Mush, you're already dealing them.
I was like, no, I'm not.
I'm getting them as favors.
And he says, Mush, if the cops catch you,
the charge is for sale or supply.
You're supplying them.
So you're already dealing them for free.
I was like fuck, he's right.
You might as well get paid.
Yeah, I was like fuck.
I'm already dealing them for free.
I might as well.
And it made sense, and Tamo was smart.
So I was like, okay.
And then I just, by default, just like that,
I became an ectasy dealer
because I ended up getting them for my friends.
And then Tamo started like training me how to do it.
Like, you know, it's, you know,
say if you're a parent out there, and you're wondering,
how does your kid get involved in drugs?
Like someone has to show them.
You know, at least the ins and outs of how to do it.
I'd get like bags of 100.
And, he like, you know,
he'd tell me how much to charge,
and not to give people credit, and you know,
all the ins and outs of it,
how to watch it out for the cops, all this kinda stuff.
And just like that, it just seemed to happen
in a short period of time.
I was supplying the whole college with em, you know?
Yeah, all of your dealing over the years though,
through San Francisco seems to be purely motivated
on your part just to have a little extra cash
and to be able to have an infinite supply for yourself.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean, you weren't trying to be
some kind of gangster kingpin in terms of dealing.
You just wanted to make sure that you always had access
to the drugs that you wanted.
Pretty much, especially at the beginning.
But then later I started,
it started to get way more serious in terms of like,
you know, doing bigger things.
But at the beginning, that's all it was, you know,
but the problem was, so at the beginning, ecstasy was great.
There wasn't even much of a come down.
You'd be awake all night,
and the come down wasn't too bad at the beginning.
But what happens when you're doing ecstasy,
probably the same as everything, the more of it you do,
the more of it you need to do.
So like one or two pills used to do me for a night
at the beginning.
And then later I wouldn't even come up
unless I double dropped like,
and in Ireland they were cheap.
Like back then they were about 10 pounds a piece
for one pill, and I was getting them
for three or four pounds a piece in bulk.
So when they're cheaply available,
and when they're not working as good,
you end up just taking more and more and more, you know?
And that's what happened to me.
The tolerance went up, and.
But then the come down, you get that depression.
The come down got worse too, yeah.
The highs were very, very high,
and the lows were really, really low.
And, you know, I started dating this girl,
we'll call her Tabitha.
I was madly in love with her like,
and before I started doing ecstasy,
I don't think I could even experience the emotion of love.
I was like really, really closed off and stuff like that.
But when I started doing ecstasy, I was like, you know,
I think it did something to my personality
that wasn't there before.
And I was madly in love with this chick.
And we were going out for awhile,
and she would always end up
getting me into fights with people.
I remember one time I was staying at her house one night,
her bedroom was on the second floor,
and I was sound asleep in bed.
I'd say it was about one o'clock in the morning.
And I wake up and she's screaming, Richie, Richie, Richie.
I fucking wake up, right,
and the window was right beside the bed.
And it was up on the second floor.
And there was a fucking man at the window.
And she was screaming, Richie, Richie.
I was like, this guy was trying to get into the house.
It was a wooden window that opens out.
I'm telling you, I opened the window,
and I beat the fucking shit out of him with the window.
I beat the crap out of him with the window,
and he didn't fall off the roof,
but he got down and ran away.
And then I woke up, and I saw Tabitha,
and she had her boobs out, like, you know,
and then I kinda realized
she must have been flashing the dude outside the window
while I was asleep.
And the guy fucking climbed up on the roof
to try and get into bed with her.
And I get woken up,
and I'm beating this guy with a fucking window, you know.
Second floor, I mean, if he had fallen
and cracked his head.
Yeah, and then the next day,
now this would only happen in Ireland.
This would never happen in America.
The next day I'm sitting in the living room with her
and her roommate, and the doorbell rings.
And it's the guy from last night.
And I looked out the window, and I saw him and his,
the poor guy, I gave him a bad, old beaten with the window.
Like I probably hit him about 20 times with it.
His face was all swollen and cut,
but I thought he was coming back to get me,
so I grabbed the fire, like the poker out of the fireplace
and I came out like and, but she answered the door,
but the guy just came to apologize.
He, like, I guess he sobered up and realized what happened.
This would only happen in Ireland like,
but the guy came to apologize.
Can you imagine in LA?
That would never happen in America, you know?
But the dude had come back to apologize,
and she answered the door, and she saw his face,
and I'm behind her with the poker.
And I was gonna fight him with the poker
cause I didn't know what was happening.
And she was trying to invite him in for a cup of tea
because she felt bad.
And all he wanted to do was apologize
and hope that she wasn't gonna call the police, you know?
Well now I know why John and Dave
wanna make a TV show out of this
cause the thing about the book and these stories
as sort of, you know, horrid and awful
as some of this stuff is
like there's this undercurrent of hilarity.
Like there's a lot of comic relief in all of this.
Oh, yeah, you have to have a dark sense of humor.
Without making excuses for your violent behavior,
and obviously people were hurt and all of that.
Like just I'm imagining in my mind,
like what that must have looked like,
like it's very cinematic.
Yeah, I don't think that one
even made it into the book, but.
Yeah, no I didn't.
Yeah, but, but.
But I think the thing too,
like to go back to something you said a few minutes ago,
you said that you couldn't access that feeling of love
until you took ecstasy.
And I think it's an important point to make
that you make in the book,
which is like these things work, man.
And when you're an addict or an alcoholic,
something does get unlocked.
Like it is serving a purpose.
And I think in terms of talking openly
about the nature of addiction and recovery,
it's important to acknowledge like that fact.
Like they serve a purpose,
and in recovery, when you look back
and kind of regale in these stories
to acknowledge like I needed that.
And actually it did something for me,
and it worked until obviously it stopped working,
and then it became very dark and terrible.
But there is that piece there
that I think if you're being, you know,
that it's important to be honest about that.
Yeah, I'll be real about everything, you know.
Obviously it's, some of the stuff is very embarrassing,
but like if you can't be honest, like what's the point?
You know, that's the way I see it.
But basically anyway, I was madly in love with this girl,
and we ended up breaking up,
and I was pretty, pretty down about it.
And by that stage I was probably doing ecstasy
three or four times a week.
I was averaging 15 or 20 pills in a night.
So I was like, all over the place.
The head wasn't working right.
And I, and you know, I was feeling really down.
It was around the time of 9/11.
And I remember, I remember one day
I decided to get two bottles of Jack Daniels.
I was just kinda drowning my sorrows, you know,
so I brought them to the house, and I was like,
I was drinking these bottles of JD.
And then, you know, I end,
I got more and more depressed and I said, fuck it.
I'll just kill myself.
You know?
And I had 100 ecstasy.
I started with a handful of five.
So I started just drinking,
like drinking and swallowing the ecstasy,
started putting out cigarettes on my arm.
I still have these scars on my arm
from where I was doing that and got a knife
and started cutting my hand.
It was like, I barely even remember it.
But what happened was I took about 30 pills,
and one of my roommates, this guy called Travis,
we'll call him Travis,
Travis hid the rest of my pills and saved my life.
Like and I was like shitting myself.
And I blacked out.
Nobody brought me to the hospital, would you believe?
Yeah.
And, but I survived.
Like, you know, it was crazy.
That was like my first suicide attempt.
I'd say I was about 19 years old.
But yeah, like down through the years,
I'd say I probably, before I got sober,
like I'd say I probably, I lost count of the number of times
I tried to kill myself
and like that one was pretty pathetic,
but some of them were kind of funny
if you have a dark sense of humor.
Like I remember one time around 2008, 2009,
I had a life insurance policy, right,
in case something happened to me,
the misses and the kids would be okay, you know?
I used to used to party with my life insurance agent.
This guy called Chris, and anyway, I was on the tear,
drinking loads and doing loads of drugs.
And I decided, fuck it.
I'll just kill myself.
And, but I was like, oh, what if,
if I kill myself, will that nullify the fucking policy
for the life insurance?
So I'm outside my house, smoking cigarettes,
like planning my death, and I ring up Chris.
He's like, hey Richie, what's going on?
I say, hey, Chris, if I kill myself,
does that nullify the policy?
And he says, he says, yeah, you fucking idiot.
It's fucking suicide.
I was like, shit.
I don't wanna fucking leave my fucking kids penniless.
And you know what he said to me
that just snapped me out of it that night?
He said, Richie, you're like a fucking fat kid
who's crying because he can't eat his fucking cake.
That's what he said to me.
And for some reason that just snapped me out of it.
It was weird.
I had loads of in incidents like that,
like another time I'd say it was maybe around 2007, 2008.
I used to be a carpenter.
When I came to America, I learned how to be a carpenter.
I was a drug dealer, but also a carpenter.
And this buddy of mine, Dav,
he had a side job for me to do on the weekends.
He says, he calls me Fetch.
So he say, hey, Fetch,
do you wanna do a side job at the weekend?
I says, yeah, what is it?
He says, it's at a fortune teller's up in Laguna Honda.
You have to, you have to like,
she wants to build a couple of walls or some shit.
I was like, okay.
But the night before I was on like a really bad bender.
So I was dying while I was working.
And I was thinking about killing myself
while I was working at this fortune teller's.
You know, she was very nice.
And I was working away.
I was putting down my plates,
nailing them with a nail gun,
and she's watching me while I'm working.
And I'm thinking, you know what, when I'm done here,
I'll go to the fucking bridge,
the Golden Gate Bridge.
Cause a lot of people kill themselves
on the Golden Gate Bridge.
So I'm nailing my plates, and I'm thinking,
I'll go to the bridge when I'm done.
And then I was thinking, fuck, you know,
there's a net around the Golden Gate Bridge,
so if you jump in the wrong place, you'll end up in the net.
So I was thinking, fuck, knowing my luck,
I'd probably end up in the fucking net, you know?
And I'm nailing my studs,
and she's watching me, and then I'm thinking, you know what?
I'll just go down there
to the middle of the Golden Gate Bridge,
and I'll blow me brains out.
Nobody ever kills themself with a gun
on the Golden Gate Bridge.
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah, I'll do that.
You know?
And this is while I'm working, I'm debating with myself
how I'm gonna kill myself,
and the fortune teller is watching me,
and she looks at me and she goes,
oh my God, you have a wonderful aura.
And I was, I just, it was so ridiculous.
I laughed out loud.
I was thinking you fucking fraud.
I didn't say anything to her,
but the ridiculousness of what she said to me
snapped me out of it for that day.
It was so, so bizarre.
Like I had so many of those moments cause like.
Yeah, little, little interventions.
Yeah.
You weren't even aware of,
but amongst all of these efforts to end your life,
did it ever enter your mind
like maybe I should get off the drugs and alcohol?
Like a normal person who's listening to this,
like I understand where you're coming from.
But a normal person is thinking,
dude, it's the drugs and the alcohol, man.
Just quit that shit.
Well, you know, I knew I had a problem
with the drugs and alcohol,
but I didn't put two and two together
about the depression being linked to the drugs and alcohol.
Like, as I said, growing up,
I had no idea of what alcoholism really is, you know?
I just basically thought it was someone
who couldn't handle their shit.
I didn't realize that part of it is
it can make a person so depressed
that they want to end their life, you know?
So I thought they were two separate issues, you know?
Until I got sober and I found out,
oh, that's part of the deal, you know?
Depression is part of the deal, but yeah,
no, like it crossed my mind, but when I was younger,
like in my early 20s, I was like,
this is what people do in their 20s, right?
And I kind of thought
maybe I'll quit some time in the future.
Maybe like when I'm 30, you know, if I live that long,
That's kinda what I thought and.
Those goal posts, keep moving 'em out.
Exactly, yeah, I moved the goal post every time.
And what, the funny thing was
a lot of times after a really bad bender,
I'd be fucked for a day or two after it.
And then during that day or two,
I would kind of think maybe I need to quit this shit, okay.
Or maybe if pissed off the wife
or if I did something or maybe went missing
or whatever I was doing,
I would make promises to her as well.
Like, you know, because I wasn't fucking behaving
like husband of the year or anything like that, you know?
So I would make, and at times I would really mean it.
I'd be like, okay, I'm never drinking again,
never doing coke again.
And then after I would feel better, after whatever week,
once I start to recover,
I thought my mind was changing.
For a lot of years, I thought I changed my mind.
I wanted to quit last week,
but I don't wanna quit this week.
And then my mind would change.
And I thought that was me changing my mind.
For a lot, a lot of years, I thought that was me
that was changing my mind each time.
But then eventually after a lot of years,
I was 28 when I got sober,
eventually it became obvious to me
that it wasn't me that was changing my mind.
It was something else that I was fucking powerless over.
Like if you're, you know, if you have a problem
with the booze and the drugs,
it's a very sneaky fucking mental condition
because it'll tell you you don't have a problem, you know?
And I used to hang around with a lot of dudes
who like in my perception were worse than I was
cause I could look at Eric or whoever I'm hanging out with
and go I'm not as bad as Eric.
Look at him, you know?
But it's a defense mechanism.
Sure, it's a wise strategy though.
Yeah, but it.
So that you don't really have to own your own shit.
Yeah, but it happens even,
it happens beyond your own consciousness.
It fucking works in the background.
It's weird.
Yeah.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the PlantPower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff, people,
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
You mentioned Travis and Tamo.
I wanna talk about the kidnapping.
This is where shit gets serious.
Oh, God.
So after a couple of years of working with Tamo
or working for Tamo, I could never seem to get ahead.
I was always, always ended up owning him more money.
He'd give me a hundred pills,
and I would end up either taking most of them myself
or giving them away
and not being able to collect the money.
And he, you know, he was throwing good money after bad.
He would keep giving me more chances, giving me more pills.
This guy guy seems incredibly patient
given the fact that you were a terrible drug dealer.
In fairness, yeah, he was.
You know, but so I was my own best customer.
That was the problem.
So I never got rich or anything like that.
I was a disaster.
And so I ended up owning him a lot of money.
And this guy Travis that I used to live with, he was,
we were only 19 or 20 at the time.
We were only kids still, but this guy was in his 30s.
He was a good dude.
He was kind of a hippie.
You know, he was from down south in Cork,
and like nice fella,
wore glasses, you know, harmless, right?
And Tamo was a wholesaler.
I was like a street dealer at that time.
So he would be giving large amounts of drugs
to different people.
And this guy, Travis, he got a few kilos of hash on credit.
And so, in Ireland we say on tick,
that means basically on credit.
So he gets the couple of kilos and then just disappears.
Just stop answering his phone.
With no intention of paying it back, you know.
Like he wasn't telling Tamo to fuck off.
He was just saying, just ignoring him.
And then so Tamo had got that on credit from his supplier.
We had a bigger supplier we used to go to
down in place called Navin.
We called this boy Smiling Pat
cause he was always smiling.
But he was, he was really dangerous.
Anyway, Tamo's supplier Pat was getting impatient
for the money.
He's ringing up Tamo and putting power tools on the phone,
like saws and shit like that.
And saying this is what you're gonna get
if you don't pay that fucking money for what you owe.
So I owe money to Tamo.
Travis owes money to Tamo, and Tamo owes money to Pat.
So that's where the dilemma started.
And at the time Tamo had this roommate up in Dublin,
this guy called Mick, he was a British guy.
Mick was like a shit bag.
He borrowed a load of Coke
off a bunch of different gangsters up in Dublin.
And they were shooting at Tamo in the street
and everything like that.
They tried to kill him over that.
Like, so I was like Tamo told me, and I was like,
what kind of a gun was it, you know?
He goes Mush, I didn't stop the look at it.
There were firing shots at me in the fucking street,
you know?
So we're all in a lot of trouble, right?
But I'm trying to pay Tamo back.
I'm his friend, so he's not really mad at me,
but he is getting upset.
And so the word is that Travis's parents
have money.
So Tamo says, okay, Mush, if you help us kidnap Travis,
I'll write off your debt,
and we'll get his parents to pay the money that he owes.
So I'm like, fuck, that's really serious shit.
And Travis had saved my life before.
He wasn't a bad dude, even though he owed the money.
So I was like, if you guys are gonna kill him,
I'm not fucking helping you with that.
He doesn't deserve to die, you know?
So he goes no, Mush, swear to God, we won't kill him.
And Tamo was actually Catholic enough, like he really,
if he swears to God, you believe him.
You know, I did anyway.
So he said, so Tamo lived in Dublin,
and I lived in outside Dublin in a different town.
And Travis lived in my town, and he goes,
Mush, soon as you see him, fucking call me.
I'll be down with the boys from Dublin.
We'll take 'em to a safe house
and make his parents pay the money.
So my job was to like find him and let the boys know.
So one day I'm down in this bar called The Roost.
It's like a busy fucking crowded place with like a DJ,
you know, a college bar.
So I'm down in The Roost one night,
and I see Travis, and I message Tamo.
And I said, he's here in The Roost.
And Tamo rings me.
He goes, Mush, stay on him.
We'll be down from Dublin.
Stay on him.
Don't fucking lose him.
Let me know if he moves, right?
So I'm watching him, and then eventually
he moves to go to another bar.
There's one up the street called Caulfields.
It's like an old man's pub, like quiet, fucking.
There might be five people there.
Dead, like, so I follow him up to Caulfields,
and I'm waiting there with Tamo,
and he's just having a pint of Guinness by himself.
Just fucking enjoying himself.
Place is empty and quiet like,
and next thing, Tamo arrives.
He had a separate crew of boys from Dublin.
Like there was me and the other boys we hung around with
who were young lads, but Tamo was like my age.
He was only 19 or 20,
but he had these older ex-cons who like followed him round
up in Dublin.
And like, he had a separate crew of boys from Dublin
who were like really dangerous fellows, you know,
like ex-cons, you know?
They were probably in their 30s, I'd say by that point.
But in he walks with the boys, with his crew from Dublin,
and I'm standing there watching,
and Travis just looks up, and he sees the boys
fucking in front of his table.
And he looks at 'em, and he goes,
Mush, come on, you're coming with us up to Dublin.
And he didn't, he didn't fight.
He didn't kick or scream.
He just fucking got up.
He took it like a man and walked out.
Right, but he knew the shit was real.
Well, yeah, because he owed like thousands of pounds
at the time.
That was before the Euro changeover,
so it would've been pounds.
We had pounds at the time.
Actually, when we changed from pounds to euros,
Tamo had to change my debt from,
okay, so you owe me 1,000 pounds.
That's equal to 1,256 euros.
We had to like change over what was owed to fucking euros.
Like, but yeah, so the boys walked out with Travis like,
and then until I seen them walking out with him,
I felt okay about it.
You know, I was like the guy owes the monies.
We're doing the right thing.
But then when I seen them walking out with him,
I was like, fuck, he might not make it back alive.
Like, you know, they might,
and then I felt really bad about it.
And you know, he had saved my life before too
that time I was gonna kill myself.
So I felt terrible about it, you know?
Right.
Yeah, but it was outta my control.
Like so then later I found out what happened off Tamo.
Basically they brought him to the safe house.
The safe house was Tamo's own house in Dublin.
They didn't have a fucking safe.
No real safe house.
Yeah, they didn't really have a safe house.
Brought him to his fucking house like,
and they brought him up there,
and they were trying to scare him.
And Tamo's brother, he's a really nice fella.
He's a gay dude.
Anyway, Tamo's brother comes in
with like a tray full of tea to the boys
while they're in the middle of it.
And Tamo was like, Mush, get out the fuck.
You're ruining the mood like.
You know, it sounded funny to me like,
but first of all, Travis was saying,
oh, my parents don't have any money, you know?
And then eventually Tamo went out to the kitchen.
He brought out some trash bags, and he says,
Mush, you pay the fucking money
or you're going in the fucking bin bags.
And then at that, Travis rang the parents,
and they drove up with the money.
I dunno what it was, five or six grand, I think,
plus each of the kidnappers got 500 a piece,
plus whatever I owed, like,
so they had came up with the cash,
and Tamo told me they were supposed to,
they met in like a deserted parking lot, you know.
Tamo came, and he put one of those scarfs around his face,
so they couldn't see his face,
and Travis's mother had the money,
and she said, please don't hurt him.
And Tamo was like, Mush, I don't know nothing about it.
I'm just here to pick up the money, you know?
And she gave the money.
They let him go.
That was the end of it.
Yeah, so when it comes time for you to make amends
for your role in this whole thing,
it creates quite a dilemma for you.
Yeah, yeah.
But now you've written about it in a book.
And even though you're using different names,
these people have.
These are all real people, yeah.
But yeah, it's not fair to use their real names.
Yeah, so that's a tricky one, right?
Like how do you make this wrong right?
Yeah, later on like part of sobriety is
when you're working the steps,
you have to make amends to people you've hurt.
When I was doing my amends list, he was,
he was the top of my list.
Like my sponsor was this guy called Bernard,
and he says, well, show me your list.
And I took out the list.
At the top of the list was kidnap Travis.
And, you know, for the amends,
you're supposed to run it by your sponsor.
So, you know, might be something like money owed
or whatever, so I would always try and, excuse me,
figure out in my head ahead of time
what the amends might be, you know?
And so I was thinking, what's the opposite of a kidnapping?
I could send him on a lovely vacation.
You know, that's what I was thinking in my head
when I first got sober,
and I was talking to my sponsor about it.
And I told him, I says,
do you want me to send him on a vacation?
He says, does that man know
you're involved in the kidnapping?
I says, no.
He says, well, don't fucking tell him.
He says it's probably the worst experience
of the man's life.
Just don't fucking kidnap anyone again.
And that was the amends.
It was just leave the guy alone,
just don't ever don't ever do that kind of stuff again.
But now at some point he might come across the book.
Well, I'd make amends to him.
So you might have to reopen that case.
Yeah, Travis, if you're out there,
let me know what I can do.
Right, there might be a vacation coming your way.
Might be a vacation in your future, yeah.
Well, at some point you pull this geographic
and move to San Francisco, right.
Thinking like, oh, if I just get outta Dodge,
all will be rainbows.
Yeah, make a long story very short.
I thought that Ireland was the problem.
Maybe if I got out of Ireland
that my fortunes would change, you know?
And I got married really young.
My ex-wife was from San Francisco,
and that's how I ended up moving there when I was 22.
I became a dad, and I tried to be good really
at the start when I got there.
And I was good for a few years, but eventually things,
I couldn't keep myself.
Well, you brought yourself with you.
Exactly, yeah, not,
the only thing that changed was the location.
I didn't change.
Right, right.
I mean, there's so many stories and incidents that you have,
but the one thing that I do wanna hear from you about
is how you got involved with this Asian gang.
I didn't even realize that was funny
until I started working with John.
You know, I told I was in this Asian gang.
He's like, you were in an Asian gang?
I'm like, yeah.
And he goes, but you're not Asian.
I was like, oh yeah, yeah, I guess I'm not.
He said, well, what were you doing with the Asian gang?
I was like, well, they had the best cocaine.
You know, around recession time,
there was no more work for a carpenter.
And I was broke, and I had a bad enough cocaine habit.
So I started dealing again
because I couldn't afford to just be a user anymore.
And I started off getting this like crappy Coke
from this Irish guy I knew, this little Irish guy.
His nickname was The Pony.
So The Pony was giving me this crappy Coke
for 800 bucks an ounce.
And it wasn't that strong.
And I don't know if you know anything about drug dealing,
it's way easier to sell stuff that's strong than not.
So I was selling this crappy Coke
that I got off The Pony,
and I used to get my own Coke off these Asian guys.
They were like organized crime, like professional dudes.
And they had really, really strong Coke.
It was extra money per gram,
but it was like pure, like uncut fish scale,
the shiny Rocky stuff, the good stuff.
So I was getting my own stuff off them for whatever,
a couple of years.
And I was finding it hard to sell the shitty Coke.
And then I came up with the idea,
why don't I ask these guys to buy the bulk off them?
You know?
And the main guy.
We'll call him Ronald.
I says to Ronald, one day,
I says, hey, can I start getting ounces off you guys?
And he knew me for a while at this point.
And he goes, you can get it under one condition.
And I'm like, what's that?
He says, if you start getting it off us,
you're not allowed to get it off anybody else.
I'm like why?
He said because we have really good shit.
And if you're working with us
and then you stop working with us
and then you start selling crap,
then it'll ruin our reputation.
So I was like, fuck, that's a bit of a commitment,
but they had the best Coke around.
So I was like, okay.
And then he says, there's one other thing.
If you ever rat on us, we'll kill your whole family.
And I was like fuck.
Like, well, I never ratted on anybody before.
I wasn't gonna start now.
So I was like, yeah, I can, I can.
That's not a problem.
Yeah, I was like.
But you were the ultimate, I mean, were you, how did you,
I guess you had established some level of trust,
but like, how do you ingratiate yourself
into that community of people?
I mean, you were,
there couldn't have been any other non-Asian people
working with that gang.
Well here, I'll tell you now, right?
So just to finish how I was, how I joined those guys.
So he says, if you ever rat on us,
we'll kill your whole family.
And I said, okay, I won't rat on you.
And he goes, if you're ever arrested,
just keep your mouth shut,
and a lawyer will be provided for you.
That's what he told me.
And he said, and the other good about working with us,
if anybody fucks with you,
we'll be up there with machine guns.
I was like fuck, okay, this is really serious.
So that was me in with them.
But before that, I had got Coke off other people as well,
but in San Francisco,
might be the same now, I don't know.
But there's a few Asian gangs
that supply all the Irish people with Coke.
There's a chick, a Vietnamese chick.
I won't tell you what her name is,
but she's one of the big, big suppliers there.
And then there was my guys, Ronald and Leroy.
Leroy was kinda like off the boat Asian dude.
He like never wore any shoes or socks when he was driving.
You know?
And then there was another guy called Johnny Go Anywhere.
He was another Asian taxi driver.
He had these business cards that said
Johnny Taxi Go Anywhere.
So his nickname was Johnny Go Anywhere.
But Johnny got killed around 2007, 2008.
Yeah, somebody called him to go somewhere,
and he pulled up on the sunset,
and they shot him in the head,
and his car drove into a fucking house and exploded.
Wow.
But yeah, the word was that the chick,
the other rival killed him,
but I heard it was Chinese money lenders, but yeah,
long story short, there's a lot of Asian gangs up there.
Yeah, so you start working with this Asian gang.
You're dealing, you're married.
You got a girlfriend.
You're out all night.
Like it seems pretty insane.
Then you have this accident on a construction site
that breaks your back.
Like there's a lot of chaos that's come into your life.
Well, I had the accident after I got sober.
Oh, that happened after.
Yeah, yeah, I was all good while I was using,
and you know, things were, well, it wasn't all good,
but yeah.
So yeah, I was working with these Asian guys for a while
and selling Coke, and I was selling Viagra as well.
Yeah, there's a thing,
I don't know if any of you Coke heads out there.
There's a thing where if you take too much Coke,
you get this thing called Coke Dick.
So if you have Viagra with you,
you can avoid that situation.
Right.
You know?
Right, right, right.
Yeah, so it's, I used to sell
the little blue pills as well.
That was part of my thing.
But yeah, things got really crazy around 2009.
But walk me up into the bottom.
Yeah, this is coming to the bottom.
Yeah, yeah, this is coming to the bottom, so.
Let's just say somebody hurted somebody I really cared about
and I decided they'd have to be killed, right?
And so I went about hiring a hitman to kill this guy.
And first I tried my gang.
I asked Ronald, would they do it for a price?
And he said that they would only kill somebody
who had fucked us over in business.
He wouldn't kill anybody for personal reasons.
And he told me he had killed a bunch of people
when he was younger, and he told me that they haunted him,
you know?
So he was trying to talk me out of it.
I didn't wanna, or he didn't wanna do it.
And then I knew this Norteño guy,
Mexican mafia fellow called Joe.
And I asked Joe, would he do it?
And Joe said, he'd do it for $5,000.
I only had $2,000.
So I says, Joe, I'll give you two.
I only have 2,000.
He's like, no, no, that's not enough money.
So then I decided I was gonna rob this bar in San Francisco.
So there used to be, it's gone now,
but it was a money laundering operation
for the Irish terrorists, and.
This just sounds like such a good plan.
Well, cocaine gave me these kinda good ideas, you know?
I mean, it's a comedy of errors,
like out of a Cohen brothers movie.
Yeah, but the sad thing is it's fucking true.
Like, so basically this place
would have a half million dollars
behind the bar every Friday.
So if you had a check, and if you were
say if you had problems with the IRS or child support
or you were an illegal immigrant,
you could bring your check into the bar,
and they'd cash the check for you and give you cash for it.
And you'd tip the bar man.
That's how the thing worked.
And I knew somebody who worked there,
and I said, well, I knew it could be robbed,
but it was like a two man job.
Like one person would have to watch the customers,
and the other person could go and get the money.
And so I was like trying to get some of the guys
I hung around with to do it, but they were all too scared.
And then I asked the girlfriend to do it with me.
And she was scared too.
And we ended up not being able to do it.
And then I get a call from Joe, Joe got a DUI.
So then he badly needed the money.
He says I'll kill the guy for $2,000.
Just you have to get the gun.
So $2000, isn't a lot of money.
So he's not spending that fucking money on getting the gun.
So I had to provide the gun for him, and I had my own gun,
but it was a legal one.
And you can't, if you have a registered gun,
you can't kill somebody with that because it can be traced.
Sure.
So I hit up this guy, Silva, another fellow I knew.
Asked him if he could give me a gun.
And he said, yeah, come to the mission.
And before this, I had been on like a really bad bender.
It was around Burning Man time.
And this undertaker from Ireland was going to Burning Man,
and he wanted a half ounce of Coke.
So I got an ounce.
Gave him half the ounce, and the other half went up my nose.
So I was awake for a few days.
And I drove down to the mission to meet Silva.
And I was like sleep walking around the place,
sweaty, fucking on edge, you know?
And when I got there, he saw how bad I was.
And he is like, I'm not giving this fool a gun, you know?
Right.
He didn't say that to me,
but I know that's what he was thinking.
So I ended up not getting the gun off him.
So I'm driving back to my house up by the beach,
and fucking cops start following me.
I was driving up Fulton, and the cops followed me.
And I'm all sweaty,
and I have an ounce in the glove compartment,
and I have a 22 under the seat.
So I'm sitting in a jail sentence if they catch me.
Yeah.
So they fucking followed me.
And then the lights come on and the siren,
and I'm like fuck.
I'm nearly having a heart attack.
And then they turned around and went back the way they came.
They must have got a call on the fucking, on the radio.
And I nearly had a heart attack.
My heart was coming through my chest.
So I pulled over, I smoked like fucking five cigarettes.
And I was like, I'm not going to jail for killing this fool.
And I decided, I decided I would go to Australia.
Right, instead.
As one would, right?
Yeah, so, so yeah, I figured I was like, fuck it.
I thought San Francisco's the problem.
I need to get the fuck outta here.
Right.
Like there was a recession in America,
but Australia was booming.
There was loads of Irish going to Australia.
So I decided to go to Australia.
Fucking hopped on a plane.
But make long story short, I hopped on a plane
on New Year's Eve or New Year's day,
and I went to Australia.
I was never gonna come back.
And I was like fuck America, you know?
Yeah, and you went with your girlfriend.
Yeah, I took the girlfriend.
And your wife was at home in San Francisco.
Yeah, yeah.
Like the insanity level is through the roof
on all of this.
Different level, like, and the other thing was,
I didn't even want the girlfriend to come with me
because like this was towards the end of 2009,
and I was like really suicidal,
but I thought if I could get out of America,
I wouldn't do it like.
And I was staying at the girlfriend's house,
and I was, I was so fucking high.
And I just wanted to book my flights to Australia.
You could get a visa online.
It was really easy.
Like I just wanted to book my flights
and get the fuck out of there.
And she was an accountant, right?
The girlfriend was.
And so she wanted to give two weeks notice.
She wanted to give two weeks notice before we leave.
And I was like, no, no, I can go now.
And you can meet me over there.
I can't wait two weeks.
I was on death's door.
And I got on the computer in her house
to fucking book my tickets for Australia,
and she turned the internet off in the house.
And I was like fuck, I'm trapped in daily city.
And she came back in, and I was high as a kite.
And she told me that raccoons had eaten the cables outside
and that's why the internet was off.
And I was high, but I wasn't that fucking high.
I knew that she turned the fucking internet off
because she wanted me to wait.
So I was stuck there, and I was like so wasted.
I couldn't go to like an internet cafe
or something like that,
they woulda called the police.
I was so bad.
So I was stuck there, and I was like mad at her
for keeping me there.
You know, in the end, she eventually turned on
the fucking internet and everything.
And we both left on New Year's Eve,
and then I was thinking, I'm finished with this chick
as soon as we get to Australia.
Right, and you go to Australia, it's a disaster,
pillar to post.
Yeah, more of the same shit, lots of fighting,
fist fights, lots of visits to the whore house,
lots of drinking.
It was crazy in Australia too, like, yeah.
So where do you, where do you meet your maker?
And finally realize like I can't, I can't do this anymore.
So I stayed in Australia for like three or four months,
and I missed the kids as well.
So I decided to come back to America.
And then when I came back.
You had two kids at this point.
Yeah, two kids, yeah.
And, yeah, and I came back,
and I was trying to be sober,
and in the end I just became suicidal.
I was gonna shoot myself again.
And, you know, even though I was a drug addict,
I was a pretty good carpenter, right?
I could always get work.
And there's a bunch of Irish guys in San Francisco
who were sober, and they go to the 12 step meetings,
and they don't make any secret of it.
And I ended up working with some of these guys,
and one of 'em was a guy called Bernard
or Americans would say Bernard.
But American Irish call him Bernard.
So Bernard, he knew I had a problem,
and we used to work together.
And I would always be curious about the meetings.
I would like ask him questions and shit.
What goes on at these meetings?
And he didn't wanna tell me a whole lot,
but he just gave me his number.
And he says, if you ever want to get sober, gimme a call.
So I says, right.
And for some reason that time I was suicidal again,
I decided to give him a call.
And because I had already tried to kill myself so many times
and it, you know, wasn't working out,
and I tried to do it on my own.
Like I tried to stop drinking.
My record was three months like off everything, and.
Yeah, but every good alcoholic has that experience
of a couple months off, which just fuels that idea
that you can do it yourself.
Yeah, like the game is to prove you're not an alcoholic.
So like, I could stay sober for three months,
so that proves I'm not an alcoholic.
Let's drink.
You know?
By the end of the three months,
I would be bursting for a drink.
And then there was other rules, excuse me,
like alcoholics drink in the house.
I knew that.
So I never drank in the house.
I was like, uh, that's alcoholic shit.
So I'd always drink, I'd always drink at the bar.
And I knew alcoholics drank in the morning.
So I never drank in the morning.
I suffered all those hangovers for all those years.
And then when I came to the meetings,
people were like, oh yeah,
I used to drink in the morning to help me feel better.
And I was like fuck, I never did that.
I suffered all these hangovers for all these years.
So led me to this point where what made me call Barnard,
I was doing this job out in the East Bay,
and I had just tried to kill myself a few weeks beforehand.
And I knew I didn't wanna drink again.
And I would be driving home from work,
and I could feel something was pulling me to go to the bar
cause I didn't drink at home, drank at the bar.
And this something that wasn't me
was pulling me to go to the bar,
and I was able to observe it.
Whereas it had been there all along,
but it was in the background,
but I could feel there's some shit that's fucking not me
that makes me, wants me wanna drink.
So I called up Bernard, and he says, well, Richie,
how are you doing?
I says, Bernard, I have a problem with the drinking
and the drugs.
Can you bring me to a meeting?
And he goes, I'll pick you up this evening.
So he came and he picked me up, and that's,
that was Labor Day 2010.
Right.
That's where I started.
And that was it.
The guy becomes your sponsor, not immediately,
but you know, he's your Eskimo.
He brings you into this whole other world,
and hence begins the slog into sobriety.
Yeah, it was really weird.
Like, I didn't know a whole lot about sobriety.
Like in Ireland it's kind of,
at least when I was growing up, it was more underground.
Like, you know, you wouldn't know shit about it.
Like even now what, the last few years.
So it must be weird in LA
where just everybody's talking about it
like a badge of honor.
Yeah, like people in restaurants
would be like fucking working the steps
in a restaurant with their sponsor.
That was so weird to me.
Like back home, it's like so secret, you know,
when you're there.
They say, oh, he's a member.
It's like fight club or some shit back home, you know?
In Ireland you have to be really bad to go to AA.
Like, cause like when I first got sober,
I started coming home
and a lot of my old drinking buddies
like Tits and the boys like that,
I'd go to the pub to meet them, but I'd be like,
what are you drinking?
I'm like a Coke.
You're not drinking.
I'm like, no, I'm an alcoholic.
He's like you're not a fucking alcoholic.
You know?
Cause if I was an alcoholic, then they could be.
Yeah, they don't wanna have to look at their own behavior.
Exactly, yeah, yeah.
So I think, I think to hit that grade
of maybe surrender in Ireland,
you probably have to be a lot, lot worse
than over here, you know?
Right, so he brings you to meetings in San Francisco.
This becomes like your thing, man.
I mean you took, what's interesting is that
you didn't relapse.
No, I was very fortunate, but it was weird though, Rich.
It wasn't, like I never relapsed, but I was at a point
where I was willing to fucking do
whatever was suggested to me.
Right.
At least on face value.
Yeah, well talk about the willingness piece
cause that's something that I talk about all the time.
Like that idea that you can't,
you can't compel somebody to get sober.
Like it has to be this internally driven desire,
a true willingness where you're ready
and prepared to do whatever it takes.
Yeah, and I didn't even really,
at the start, I didn't even really think
it would necessarily work for me, you know,
because as I said before,
I knew I had a problem with the sauce and the cocaine,
but I thought like maybe
I have some kind of mental problems,
like maybe I'm fucking depressed or manic depressing
or bipolar or some shit like.
You know, I really did,
cause I didn't understand the mental traits
of somebody who has a problem like this, you know?
And I knew that alcoholics drank every day,
but I didn't drink every day.
I was like a, I was a binge drinker.
Like sometimes I could stay sober for a couple of weeks,
but then I would just drink to extreme when I did,
so my understanding was that I'm probably not an alcoholic,
you know, until I came there.
And then when I came to the first meeting,
I was really nervous, dude.
Like, so all the Irish know each other in San Francisco.
That's where it was.
And then I knew that the Irish Center had meetings, right?
I didn't want to go to the Irish Center.
Right, cause that'll, it'll get leaked out
and find its way back to Cavan.
Yeah, Richie Stevens has a problem.
Like, yeah, yeah.
So like I didn't mind them knowing
I was a drug dealer piece of shit or anything like that.
This is how warped my thinking was at the time.
Didn't mind them knowing that I was a drug dealer,
and I was a bad guy,
but I didn't want them thinking I had a problem.
So Barnard picked me up that day,
and there was another guy with him, Nile.
I'd never met him before,
but the two guys were in the front, and I was in the back,
and I was really nervous
cause I didn't want the fucking Irish people to know.
And this guy Nile was Irish too, who was in the car with me,
like, and I was so fucking nervous, dude.
I says, where are we going?
And Bernard says, we're going to the Irish Center.
I'm like fuck.
And the car was already moving, so I was like,
I have to go to the fucking Irish Center now, you know?
And they knew I was really nervous, you know?
And it was quiet in the car, and Bernard turns around,
and he says, did you bring your passport?
I said, what?
Did you bring your passport?
I was like, no, I thought it was like a setup with the cops
to be waiting for me to have my passport to deport me.
I says, no, why?
And then he started laughing.
He had this fucking Santa Claus laugh, (hearty laughing)
like this, but he was just breaking my balls.
Like, you know, and that kinda took the edge off.
Like they were kind of making fun of me
cause they knew I was nervous.
You know, he was just fucking with me.
So it kinda broke the ice a little bit.
We got up to the Irish Center, he parked the car,
and I was like looking around
looking to make sure nobody saw me going in
or anything like that, you know?
Cause then they'll know Richie Stevens
has a fucking problem.
That grandiosity, like anyone would give a shit.
Yeah, and this guy stopped me at the door,
like a Northern fellow called Stephen.
He says, well, how are you?
Are you new?
And I was thinking, how the fuck does he know I'm new?
You know?
But the thing is if you ever go to the meetings,
of course they know if you're new
because the same people go every week.
And if you're new, you probably look like shit as well.
So I couldn't have been looking too hot
after the session I had been on.
So I was like, yeah, I am new.
He goes, do you thank you for problem with drinking?
I says, yeah.
He says, what makes you say that?
I says, well, I just tried to kill myself
a couple of weeks ago.
And he goes, he goes, that'll do it.
Right, right.
Yeah, and then, and I went, and I sat down,
and it was a fucking,
it was a man only meeting on a Friday night,
and there was a good few Irish lads there, you know.
Like people like me, construction workers.
And I came in, and I sat down, and you know,
I knew that like from whatever I had seen on TV
or any of this shit,
I thought if you come to a fucking meeting,
you have to tell everybody your story
or you have to talk in front of a group,
and I'm like, that scared the shit outta me.
You know, I could go around carrying a gun
and deal with the people I was dealing with.
That didn't scare me,
but being honest in front of a group of other drunks
about my embarrassing shit,
that scared the shit outta me.
So I was like intent
on not fucking telling anybody anything,
sit at the back, you know, keep to myself.
And so I sat down in the back,
and everybody was shaking my hand and saying hello.
And I was just trying to keep a low profile.
And at the start of the meeting, the guy says,
have we any newcomers here tonight?
And everybody like turns around, looks at me like,
and I would've like pretend fucking
or give a fake name or something like that and just leave.
But Bernard and Nile already knew who I was.
So they put up the hand, and I was like I'm Richie.
I'm an alcoholic and a drug addict.
And I had never, I don't think I had ever admitted that
before in a group.
Like, and I couldn't believe it.
They all fucking clapped.
And I was like, wow, do you people know who I am?
Like the things I have done.
And, but they didn't give a fuck.
Some of them did, but they didn't give a shit.
All they cared about was there's a dude here
who has a problem, and you know,
we're gonna help him out for fun and for free.
And it really, I couldn't believe they were clapping for me.
They're really like not what I was expecting, you know?
Yeah, so you say that out loud for the first time,
but at what point did you believe that about yourself?
Like prior to that
because you thought it was some other mental defect
or you were making rationalizations or excuses for yourself,
but deep down when your head hit the pillow, you knew,
like you knew you were an alcoholic and a drug addict.
When I started drinking at the age of 15 or 16,
I knew I had a problem back then, but.
You push it way down.
Yeah, like I remember one time going to the doctor.
You know, when you go to the doctor's office,
and there's a bunch of leaflets and shit like that
sitting around, and it's in Ireland, same as here.
You'd have a bunch of leaflets and shit
in the doctor's office.
I remember when I was a kid, like a teenager,
I saw one of these leaflets,
and it was an alcoholic questionnaire.
I think it's called "The 20 Questions."
Yeah, yeah.
I think that's what it's called.
So I remember as a kid fucking opening this shit up
when I was at the doctor's office,
and I had just discovered drinking at this time,
and I'm reading through the questions.
Do you ever do things you regret while you're drinking?
Ah, who doesn't.
Do you ever lie about your drinking?
Of course.
You know, have you ever blacked out?
Ah, it happens to everybody.
And I remember back then, when I had done the questionnaire,
I probably got 16 or 17 out of 20.
And if you ever do that questionnaire, they say one yes
means you might be an alcoholic.
Two yeses mean you're probably an alcoholic.
Three or more, you are definitely an alcoholic.
So I saw it in black and white
when I was a fucking teenager,
but I thought it was a joke.
You know, I was like, everybody drinks in Ireland, you know.
It's like, it's in our culture.
It's in our blood.
Like, you know, so I knew I had a problem from the start,
but when you're doing the steps, right,
it's admit it, you're powerless over drugs and alcohol,
and your life is unmanageable.
So I knew I was powerless from a teenager,
but I thought my life was manageable.
If you looked from the outside looking in,
you'd say this guy's a fucking, a fiend, like, you know,
but until the very end, I probably hadn't admitted
that second part that my life was unmanageable.
Right, right.
And that's the baffling thing.
Cause any outside observer would say
this is nothing but chaos and insanity,
but your lived experience was, right, this is under control.
I'm managing this all right.
Yeah, in my own head, you know,
but obviously not in everybody else's head.
No.
The people I was working with, you know,
the dolls I was seeing, my wife, obviously.
Yeah, we're gonna get to the wife.
But first, you know, one of the things I appreciated
about the book is your candor
around the character defect piece.
Because there is this idea that when you get sober
like it's just about getting rid of the drugs and alcohol,
and then all my problems are gonna go away.
And what you don't realize is that then, you know,
you have all of these emotions that come to the surface
that become very unmanageable
until you learn these new tools
for how to work through them.
And in your case, like a lot of it goes back to the anger.
Yeah, like basically when you're getting sober, right,
it's really difficult when they take away your medicine
because the booze is your medicine.
If you're an alcoholic, the booze is what you use
to feel good or to deal with all your problems.
For me, like any time I had any kind of a feeling,
the impulse was to drink or get high.
Like if I was happy about something,
yay, let's celebrate.
If you're sad about something, drown your sorrows.
If you're angry about something,
need a drink to calm you down.
It was literally my solution for everything, even boredom.
Fuck, I have nothing to do.
Let's go to the bar.
So if you have a problem with drinking and drugs,
like that's your life.
And then to suddenly have your comfort taken away,
you're raw as fuck, like, you know,
so when someone's newly sober,
they're definitely really irritable.
And like you were saying with the defects of character,
there's no such thing as a perfect person.
I still have defects of character obviously,
but they're more obvious when the booze is gone,
and your head is clear,
and you have to get real about what these problems you have.
Like for me, I would say, yeah, quick to anger was one.
You know, I probably got as many beatings as I gave,
you know, but violence was a way to solve problems.
I never hit my misses or my kids or anything like that.
But other dudes, like, you know,
and that's not how you behave.
Like when I came to the meetings, they says,
it's a spiritual program.
And I said, what the fuck is spiritual?
And I have a college education,
but I never used the word spiritual.
It wasn't in my vocabulary like, and I was like,
what does that mean?
Do we all fucking sit around and do yoga
or become vegan?
Or what the fuck is that?
You know, that's what I was,
that's what I thought originally.
Maybe! (Rich laughing)
Not me, but I, but yeah, so I heard
like you'd hear these people at the meetings
and they're like, yeah, it's a spiritual program.
I said what the fuck is spiritual?
And the best definition I got,
an old priest I talked to at one of the meetings, he said,
spirituality is freedom from the bondage of self.
So I had bondage of self
that's why I was drinking and doing all these drugs.
I was like, okay, that sounds cool.
The booze and the coke used to be my spirituality.
How the fuck do I,
how do I feel good now without that stuff?
And they said, it's very simple.
You just, you just do whatever your sponsor suggests.
You try to be honest.
You try to help other people
instead of just thinking about yourself,
and you do other shit like praying and meditating
if you wanna do that kind of stuff.
Like I didn't do that kind of stuff at the beginning, but,
yeah, I slowly learned the tools to not have to drink
and get high anymore.
And it was a learning process.
And slowly my feelings started to become more normal.
The highs weren't so high.
The lows weren't so low, you know?
Right, and there's that fear that comes with that
because there is an addiction to those highs and lows
on some level.
Like what is my life gonna be like,
if I'm just flat lining all the time?
You know, I can't live that way.
Yeah.
It's gonna be boring.
It's gonna be intolerable.
Yeah, I thought, before I actually decided to get sober.
Like when I decided to get sober, there was no more options.
I was like it's either do this or die.
But before that, the concept of like getting sober,
maybe even going to meetings or something like that,
I thought it would be like the most boring shit ever.
I thought it would be like a bunch of people
fucking hanging out in the room, trying not to drink,
you know, like kinda sad and pathetic,
but it turned out to be the exact opposite for me.
The people I've met in recovery
are the most interesting people.
The people who were like me so fucked up
that they couldn't do it anymore.
You know?
And there was a lot of fun around that.
And I learned how to do normal things sober.
Like there's this thing that they do,
another new word for me was fellowship.
So I'm like what the fuck is fellowship?
Bernard said to me one day when I was new at the meetings,
I was just, I was just getting like,
I was just getting stuck in at the start.
And he says, we're going to meet for coffee.
Meet me at the coffee shop.
I says, go for coffee?
What the fuck are we gonna do there?
And he goes, we're gonna talk and drink coffee.
And that was like, that was weird to me as well
cause since I was a kid,
when you're in a social fucking surrounding,
you wanna have a beer.
And, but it was a catch 22 with me,
like before I got sober,
if I was in a social setting, some shit like this,
where I didn't really know the people,
and I might feel nervous, I'd want a beer just to feel okay.
And then the problem was once I started drinking the beer,
I drank too much beer.
And then I started making a fool of myself.
So it was even when I was drinking,
it was a no win situation.
So we had to like, so I remember the first time
we went to the coffee shop, and we were drinking coffee
and just chatting.
It was like, it was weird like,
but I got used to it fairly quick
because there was something about being around other people
who were the same as me, who had the same problem as me.
I found it to have a connection
to other people who have my problem.
There's something about talking to another fucking drunk
or another addict that they understand you, you know?
So, and I used to trip out so much about it at the start.
I'm like, oh, how am I never gonna drink again fucking?
What if my parents die?
Or what if my daughter gets married in 20 years,
and I'm at her wedding,
will I not be able to have a glass of champagne or whatever?
And Bernard, he says to me, he says, nevermind that shit.
He says, we do it one day at a time.
So today you don't feel like drinking.
Maybe tomorrow you won't either.
Don't worry about fucking 20 years time, you know?
Yeah, yeah, man.
Those annoying adages that are so true.
Yeah, yeah, there was a bunch of them
like fucking easy does it.
That was an important one for me too
cause everything was such a big deal when I got sober,
like, oh God, the wife annoyed me
or some of the boys at work,
be like a fucking Greek tragedy like, you know.
They'd say easy does it?
That means just take it easy.
Don't worry about that shit, and.
The other thing is like the levity, right?
You talk about in the book, like the first time
that you kind of really shared your whole story
in a group setting, and the fear around that,
but in that community, like it's so welcomed, right?
Like that level of,
because it takes courage to be vulnerable on that level.
Right?
But tapping into that vulnerability
becomes part of the healing process,
and we can laugh at this stuff that we've done
and that has happened in the past,
even though we're also appreciating the heaviness of it
and kind of where it took us.
And that's like a salve in the wound, right,
to sit and listen to other people's version of your story,
how they got through it, and the kind of ownership.
Like this is what happened.
I'm not ashamed to talk about it
because I've done all of this work
to repair my relationships, make peace with my past,
overcome those resentments and everything like that.
That is really like when someone walks into the room
and can share as openly as you just have
about all these things that you've done.
Like, I think that's something
that helps us feel more connected to other people.
Yeah, like for me, it didn't come easy to me.
Like, you know, I'm nearly 12 years sober now,
so I've told my story fucking at least 50 times
to groups of people,
but it was very difficult for me to share at the start
because most people who were in recovery
haven't done the things I did, you know.
Like I think the first person I heard speaking
who had a similar story to me was a Hell's Angel.
You know, and I remember when I heard his story,
and it actually gave me a kind of a sense of relief
that like, cause I always feel like I'm the worst person
in the room like, and you know,
I am ashamed of some of the things I've done.
Like you can't be proud of some of this shit.
But the bottom line is it happened
and it was at a time in my life
where I was powerless over something.
You know, I wouldn't have made
those kind of decisions today, like how I am,
and I'm not proud of like a lot of the stuff I've done,
but it happened like, you know?
It's the truth.
And I was most worried about, you know,
what if I tell these people about this shit that I've done,
and they think I'm a fucking asshole?
Like I feel like I am, you know.
What if they don't wanna know me like?
And like expecting judgment from people.
And of course some people are gonna judge you.
It's not like,
things I have done aren't things to be proud of.
Like I'm lucky I'm not dead or in jail
for the things that I have done, but I'm being,
but when I'm asked to share at a group, I do
because it might help somebody else
who like maybe feels
like they're the biggest piece of shit in the room too.
Yeah.
Like or maybe they have something that they have done
that they're not proud of, you know?
How have you stayed plugged in after almost 12 years?
Cause you really embraced the program,
and you're an ambassador, you know,
in a very service forward way to a lot of people.
Yeah, so I had a bit of bad luck
at the end of my first year.
And so after I got sober,
I turned my back on criminal lifestyle,
completely out of it.
No more, no more drug dealing or any of that kinda stuff.
And I tried to switch my life around
and fucking get everything back on track.
I tried to fix my marriage,
tried to become a productive member of society,
and I wanted to be a contractor, you know,
construction business, cause I was a carpenter.
I had the skills and experience
even though I was high as a kite
a lot of the time I had been doing it.
And so I took the test to get my contractor license,
and that's what my plan was,
I'm gonna build houses for the next fucking 30 years.
That's where I thought my life was gonna go.
That's what my plan was.
And then I got into an accident,
construction accident, and I broke my back.
A beam fell down and hit me,
broke one of my discs, herniated another one.
It's permanently damaged,
so I had to stop being a carpenter.
And it would've been very easy to go back drinking
at that time because I was feeling sorry for myself.
And I thought, oh, I got sober now.
Everything should be cool, you know?
But the thing is like whether you're sober or not
sometimes bad things happen, you know?
And what got me through that time,
it was around the time when I had just finished my steps
in the program, and the last step is
you gotta like help others, work with other people.
So I ended up sponsoring some other guys
who were trying to get sober,
and that kept me out of the self pity.
Cause there's something about working with somebody else
that it's hard to feel sorry for yourself
when you're trying to help somebody else.
You know, it's impossible to do both at the same time.
So I started working with others,
and that got me through a hard part in my life.
And I ended up doing what I'm doing now
as something I enjoy far more.
I got into acting and moved down here to LA.
But part of it is, part of it is like
if you wanna keep what you've got, you gotta give it away.
So I don't say which programs I go to, but I go to multiple.
You know, there's a few things wrong with me.
(both laughing)
So that just, you know, right, so yeah, I still,
I still try and be of service to others where I can,
and if it's not broke, don't fix it.
So I keep on doing the same shit
that I was taught at the beginning.
Yeah, there's a bit of a comparison to Barry
in your story.
Here you are this guy, you know,
who's living this gangster lifestyle, and then you become,
you become an actor, and it's hard to not like, you know,
think about Barry when I think about your arc.
I suppose it is like Barry, except mine's a true story.
Yeah, yeah, it's true.
And you weren't, you weren't a hitman.
Let's be clear.
No, I never killed anybody.
Thank God.
But it is, it is, there is a,
there's sort of a comedic undertone to that as well.
Yeah, I don't, you know, I.
You come down here,
and then you start playing gangsters and heavies
and bad guys and you know, all these procedural shows.
Yeah, well it's kinda like,
I didn't choose to do that either.
It chose me.
I didn't like start acting and go, I just,
I wanna play bad guys.
It was like, you look like a bad guy.
You'll play bad guys. (both laughing)
So that's how I.
And you've been at it for a while, man.
You're doing good.
Yeah, I've been in a lot of shows, and I enjoy it, yeah.
Yeah, the wife and the kids.
How's everything going there?
Ex-wife now.
I'm divorced.
I have a good relationship with my kids.
They were only toddlers when I got sober,
and they're teenagers now, and yeah,
I just try to be a good dad.
They live in San Francisco.
Yeah, they live with the ex-wife,
and it was kind of a weird one
because I had to tell them a bit about my story
cause they had no idea about how I used to behave
cause they were only babies when I got sober, so they.
But you're, I mean, it sounds like life for your wife
was an absolute living hell.
Oh yeah, like I'm sure
I was not fucking husband of the year
for any of those years or father of the year, you know?
Yeah, so obviously she won't have
that good of an opinion of me,
especially since we got divorced,
but there's nothing I can do about that.
You know, I just try and be a good dad to my kids,
but it's kinda weird like having to tell the kids
about some of the stuff I used to do
cause they didn't know about any of this shit.
And I was like, well, I wrote this book, and you know,
I'm gonna have to tell you some of these stories, so.
How does your ex-wife feel about the book?
You'd have to ask her about that.
Yeah, no, we're not close or anything like that,
but we co-parent, you know.
And so you go up and visit the kids or how does that work?
Yeah, yeah.
I get 'em every month, yeah.
So how does the book come about,
and this relationship with John and Dave?
Oh, so.
I mean the book opens with them talking about
how they met you and kind of it being its own little miracle
because ordinarily they would've never,
you just sort of cold emailed them.
Yeah, I did.
Ordinarily they would've never even opened that email.
They didn't know me from Adam.
So, so basically.
And explain who these guys are.
Okay, so John Altschuler and David Krinsky,
they're the co-creators of "Silicon Valley,"
and they were show runners on "King of the Hill."
They wrote "Blades of Glory," starring Will Ferrell.
Yeah, they're successful writers and show runners.
Yeah, they're big time Hollywood show runners and writers.
Yeah, and the way it came about, it was a funny thing.
So one of my buddies, a guy called Sean, Sean Mann.
He's another actor.
We moved to LA around the same time.
He's a really good guy.
And he was working on this comedy project,
and I was helping him do a little bit of producing on it.
And if you guys wanna see it, I think it's on YouTube.
It's pretty funny.
He did like a proof of concept.
It's called "Roommates."
So he says, see if you can get me someone big
attached to this, and if you can help me out.
So I was just helping Sean out.
So I was like, this is a good comedy.
It's kind of an out there comedy that he was,
he had created.
And so I looked at who were the best comedy people.
And at the time "Silicon Valley" was one of the top ones.
So I reached out to like a couple of people.
The first one was Danny McBride.
I got Danny McBride's email,
and I emailed him, and then his assistant got back and said,
we don't accept unsolicited materials.
And then I sent it to John,
and John responded, and he said this is cool.
Let's meet, and we met up with John, and.
Right, which is highly, highly unusual.
Yeah, that.
That's not, you know, that's not how things work.
That kind of shit doesn't happen really.
Yeah, usually if you send unsolicited materials
to top people.
For legal reasons alone, they don't do it.
Other than like who is this guy?
Like you're not gonna get the time of day from anybody.
Yeah, exactly.
But it just turns out that they were really nice guys,
and we ended up meeting up with them,
and that particular project wasn't a fit for John,
but he said, I like you guys, keep sending me stuff.
So I sent him another couple of things,
and he passed on those.
And then I had written my original draft of the book,
and I sent that to him, and he liked it.
And then he read like 50 pages of it.
And he says, I like this,
but I don't really know where it's going.
So then I told him about my past, and he was like,
let's meet again.
Cause the first time that we met, he had no idea
I used to be a gangster or anything like that.
I'm not scary in person.
I'm friendly like,
and then we met up again, and I told him a couple of yarns,
and he's like, wow, this is crazy.
Do you wanna partner on it?
And I said, okay.
And then, so first of all, he has another show coming out.
I'm not allowed to say what it is,
but basically it's about somebody who's an author.
And then he put us in touch with our book agents,
and the book agents read the book, and they were like
wow, this is pretty crazy, but I don't know how to sell it.
And then John had the idea of rewriting the book
in the format of the 12 steps
cause so it would be shorter and more accessible
to what my story really is.
And then we rewrote the book together,
and the book is coming out on May 24th,
and it's gonna be a TV show as well.
So what's the deal with the TV show?
Like is that a pilot deal or a series deal?
What's the status of development there?
Like how, you know, cause it's one thing like,
oh, there's gonna be a show.
There's a long, you know, a lot of things have to happen
before something ends up on the air, right?
Well, we took it into John's manager
before the book was done, and he said,
you should get a book deal first
cause it's easier to green light.
And then we got the book deal,
and we have a bunch of people
who are interested in it right now.
We dunno where it's gonna land yet.
Yeah.
But I can't really say who's looking at it,
but some cool people.
It's exciting, man.
Yeah.
It's quite an arc.
It's crazy.
When you look back on the whole thing,
it's pretty miraculous.
Yeah, it's kind of unbelievable.
Like number one that I'm alive after all this kinda stuff,
and yeah, it's pretty crazy.
Do you find that that makes it easier
to connect with gratitude and all of that?
Yeah, absolutely.
Like, you know, they told me when I got sober,
if you stay grateful, you won't ever drink again.
So I have a lot of things to be grateful for.
And, yeah.
I have a crazy life today.
But it's pretty balanced now.
Yeah, yeah, the only drama I have is on the stage now.
Thank God, and try and keep it that way.
And meanwhile, you're still auditioning
and doing that whole, doing that whole deal.
You did some movie with Halle Berry, right?
Yeah, I did that a few years ago.
That was called "Kings,"
and last year I was.
I didn't see that one.
Yeah, that was about the Rodney King riots.
And I did, last year I did "Days of Our Lives,"
and "NCIS," and I've done "Blue Bloods,"
"Criminal Minds."
All the procedurals.
"MacGyver," all that kind of stuff.
I've been bad guy of the week a lot of times, yeah.
That's cool, man.
Well, let's round this out with some words of wisdom
for the person out there who's still suffering,
whether or not they're an alcoholic or a drug addict
or just battling with some kind of substance
or addiction related issue.
How do you communicate to that person?
Throw them a lifeline and kind of, you know,
help them figure out a better path forward.
Well, I would just say like,
no matter how bad you think things are, it can still,
you can still have, it can still be fixed.
Like I kind of thought
that I was just gonna be messed up forever
and that I didn't think that it would work for me.
And I've seen it working for a lot of people.
So all you have to do is ask for help,
and the help is there if you wanna take it.
Easier said than done sometimes.
Yeah, you have to be fully cooked.
You know, the best advice I ever got
when I was out and about,
one of those sober guys, I was working with him,
and I came in really hung over like, and he says,
why do you do this to yourself?
And I looked at him, and I was like,
you think I'm an alcoholic?
He says, of course you're a fucking alcoholic.
And I was like why?
He's like, you're fucking, you're doing Coke with hookers
in motels.
Like fucking non-alcoholic don't do that shit.
And then I was like,
well, do you think I should go to the meetings?
He goes, no, not yet.
He says, keep on doing it until you can't do it anymore.
If you're not ready, it won't work.
He said, you have to.
Research.
Yeah, he says, keep going until you're cooked.
And then you'll know when you can't do it anymore,
then you go.
Yeah, if you're ready, you're ready.
It's all about willingness.
Yeah.
If you can summon that willingness and do the thing.
Like yourself, I've seen so many lives
changed and transformed, so it is possible.
And I think the real inspirational piece in your story
relates to that arc.
Like, honestly, your story's so insane.
So if you could figure this out and get sober,
like I think it provides a lot of hope to a lot of people.
Well, I didn't figure it out on my own either.
Like really, I owe my life to that guy Bernard
who brought me to my meeting, to the meetings.
Who you, the book is dedicated to him.
Yeah, he saved my life.
Like I wouldn't be alive if it weren't for that man.
How's he doing now?
He's good.
He's over in Canada, and he's married,
and he has a little baby.
Is he still your sponsor?
No, no, I have a new one now, but yeah,
cause when he moved home, I got a local guy,
but no, we still keep in touch, and yeah, I owe him a lot.
Yeah, good, man.
Well, I'm super proud of you.
I've had the privilege of bearing witness
to part of this arc.
I remember when you were telling stories
about San Francisco, like way back in the day,
and you've come a long way, my friend.
So I'm excited for this book to come out,
and for everybody to, you know, get a taste
of what your life is all about.
And I'm excited for the possibility of this new TV show.
And I feel like this is a inflection point in your life,
and I would just encourage you
to continue to tell your story
and to do it with that level of humility and vulnerability
that you did today cause I think it's really powerful.
And I think it has the potential to help a lot of people.
Thanks a million for having me, Rich.
If any of you guys haven't heard Rich before,
I would subscribe and like this podcast,
and thanks very much for having me on and.
Yeah, man.
And, yeah, if you guys wanna learn some more about me,
you can see my shit on IMDB.
It's Richie Stevens.
I'm on Instagram, richieactor,
and the book is coming out on May 24th, 2022.
It's on Amazon, Simon & Schuster, Barnes & Noble,
and Audible.
All the places, man.
So Audible, I wanted to ask, final thing.
Obviously you read the book, right?
Of course.
Yeah.
And you're this master of accents.
We got to hear a bunch today.
I didn't realize there were so many versions
of an Irish accent, but there are.
Can you understand them all?
Do you do all the voices?
Like the different voices for the different characters
in the book?
I do, yeah.
That's a reason to get it on Audible right there.
Yeah, yeah, I hope you guys understand them.
No, it's good, man.
Cool.
The book is "The Gangster's Guide to Sobriety:
"My Life in 12 Steps."
Always a pleasure to see you.
And I look forward to trudging this road alongside you,
my friend.
Thanks, Rich.
All right.
Peace out.
(upbeat music)